if you've ever done something stupid
this is your place because the host has
done some stupid stuff as a matter of
fact I have a PhD in D um B I learned
some of my most powerful lessons from
mistakes that I have made or watched
others make I am getting older though
and smarter wiser because of with all
that experience C of mistakes all those
scars I don't make as many mistakes as I
used to make when I was stupider is that
a word
C I'm probably just made a mistake just
then I'll probably get like some grammar
teacher help me stupider is probably not
a word more stupid it's probably correct
okay so I always tell you to not here's
a mistake I just made I and I know
better I know better but I did it anyway
as I'm just stupid I just naive I just
want to believe in the greater good of
people's hearts and I'm just dumb and it
gets me in trouble so I tell you not to
do business with people like you know
Bank of America why would you ever bank
with Bank of America they have no soul
whatsoever
horrible service horrible operation just
horrendous these huge mega banks I tell
you to stay away from them
I've always told you to stay away from
and you know Chase Bank and these kinds
of people why in the world would you
subject yourself to that you know go use
a good local credit union a local
community bank or at most a good
regional bank I bank with a couple of
local banks here in the Nashville market
and with a regional bank as well and
that's what I've told you to do forever
forever and so if you don't know we
started about 20 years ago well probably
more like 15 years ago with a high
school curriculum in high schools all
across America and start putting it in
and it's changed it's iterated the way
we do it's changed it's you know
textbook approved meets all the
benchmarks all these different things in
these different states and we have a
whole education solutions department
here that sells the high school
curriculum into the high schools and the
middle school curriculum into the middle
schools and the college curriculum into
colleges a lot of freshmen courses being
taught with our stuff teaching people
the stuff we teach here on the air which
don't you wish you knew that when you
were in high school right and so and it
also
with a local Catholic school here coach
teaching it out of financial piece book
100 years ago and we just hate that we
need to do that and so we developed and
iterated and evolved this tour now we
are in a little over one third of the
high schools in North America now that
happens two different ways one way it
happens is when the high school just
purchases the curriculum or the school
board or the state purchases the
curriculum and puts it in there and we
sell it to them obviously the other
thing we've had good luck with and is
started with a wonderful Bank out in
Utah called the Science Bank and Zions
Bank bought the high school curriculum
for all of the high schools in Utah and
sponsored it which was a really cool
thing to do and they're wonderful people
I've known them for a long long time and
doesn't you know when I first heard that
I went wow all the high schools in Utah
but you keep in mind you Todd is not
like super heavily populated but it's
still very generous okay it's like I
mean it's not like North Dakota but
close you know and so but they covered
all the high schools it's pretty neat
with hey let's do that again and so six
years ago we signed up with a larger
regional bank wasn't really a mega bank
but getting close called Fifth Third and
had Fifth Third Bank sponsor of the
curriculum and they've been with us for
six years sponsoring it which was really
nice run and a lot of students got help
because of that sponsorship and we were
you know consequently always saying
wonderful things about fifth or which we
believed to be true and all of this and
that sponsorship has come to an end now
I got to tell you we sell sponsorships
in live events we sell sponsorships
local radio we suspect ships national
radio we sell sponsorships to book tours
we saw hundreds of millions of dollars
of sponsorship deals over the years
hundreds I mean we do them all the time
it's what we do we love sponsors and and
sometimes things work on sponsorships
and sometimes they don't and sponsors
come and they go and they may or may not
get a good rate of return on it or or
whatever that's all cool I mean that's
just business it's just that's how life
works some things work some things don't
and so Fifth Third gave us notice that
after six years that they were no longer
going to sponsor the curriculum which
was fine I mean we would have sell it
and into the high schools and and or get
some different sponsors and you know
they were just moving on and that's cool
and it was a good partnership until
yesterday and I found out that these
slimeballs
are calling on my customers they're
calling all the high schools trying to
sell them a high school curriculum that
they wrote you unethical slime balls
unbelievable
I mean in all the years of selling
sponsorships I've never had anybody I
mean that's like coming to somebody's
party in their house and stealing their
Civil War and and here I sit shocked
that a large bank is crooked let's see
that's where I was done is I you know I
asked a snake to not bite and I'm just
dumb and then I'm small species like and
I'm sitting here shocked the snake bites
well dumb but of course they bite you're
dealing with a huge bank that has no
soul and of course where they gonna do
they're gonna write a curriculum tells
all these kids to get Visa right and use
the you know going to debt to get your
car and you know all this kind of stuff
and and teach these kids you know to go
use their product and here's the other
thing the curriculum will be crappy and
it won't work was there's other people
to do this stuff in the financial
literacy space and we're kicking all of
us but because we're the only fully
comprehensive curriculum that works and
because we don't have a conflict of
interest but we're not a wolf in the
henhouse right I mean let's put a wolf
and having sit in there and guard the
eggs right I mean that's a dollar and
crap have a bank teach you financial
principles it's a dumb idea so I mean I
can't believe it
so I got to tell you if you're on the
board of directors at Fifth Third Bank I
got to tell you you got some people that
are crooks working for you there's slime
balls and your chief marketing officer
is an absolute unethical twerp and and
it really looks bad on your bank because
there's actually some good people at the
branch level I know a bunch of my
friends work for Fifth Third there's
some good people out there working for
fifth or but I got to tell you the
chances of me ever telling me by do
anything except stay away from Fifth
Third Bank with every ounce of my energy
you can count on it because Fifth Third
you're just now on the same list with
SunTrust you're on the same list with
Bank of America you're you know you're
just another scum bank and your job is
to rip people off it's unbelievable the
lack of ethics on this kind of stuff and
I just I never I mean I'm in some dumb
businesses radio businesses you know
people break contracts in that business
all the time you expect it I
you know I'm in the publishing business
Oh Lord you wouldn't believe I mean we
deal with ad agencies you know and we
deal with all kinds of characters and
I've never had anybody just completely
steal my attempt to steal my customers
so but that see this big bank they they
forgot two things one is a we have a
curriculum that works and B we know how
to sell it and C these are my customers
meaning they have a loyalty to me and D
you picked a fight with a hillbilly so
game on boys and girls game on game on
you scum burgers
I'm serious you ought to ask for your
CEO and for sure your chief marketing
officers resignation because any
organization runs with this lack of
integrity is somebody stay completely
away from them so I'll just tell you if
you have that personal experience with v
or with operating with them with your
personal banking god help you if they
treat you the way they've treated us so
just can't let you know how things are
going that's my day for the day so now
back to you guys and but I'm so stupid I
still get to learn stuff I just get to
learn stuff Dave big banks have no soul
well duh you foolish hillbilly you
should have known that you stupid boy
well now I'm reminded and back to my
back to my life I'll go back to doing
expose do which is kick their butts
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]